rudby chalice stopped cutting trees five
years ago like everybody here she used
to log and burn the forest to make space
for cows and farming despite it being
protected land but now she tends to a
growing plant nursery part of a
community forestry program aimed at
changing the ways of farmers living in
the colombian amazon
i called it the oasis new life nursery
because it's about giving new life to
the trees that many have cut mistreated
and burned
the project financed by norway along
with colombia's foundation for
conservation and sustainable development
involves over a hundred families living
in the northern areas of the colombian
amazon
they promised to end logging in exchange
for sustainable alternatives
former coca farmer ole miss garcia is
leading a number of these projects we
met him as he was working on a live
fence made of trees a way he says to
rebuild connections between parts of the
forest
as these trees grow they stick together
and monkeys and other animals will use
them to cross from one section of the
forest to the other it's just an example
of the change in mentality of how we can
live protecting the forest
most of these projects were created
following the signing of a peace deal
with farc rebels five years ago
deforestation soared as the guerrilla
left this territory opening up more land
for cattle ranching and other damaging
activities
but it's an uphill battle criminal
groups are destroying huge swaths of the
forest deeper into the jungle while many
local farmers who abandoned profitable
coca farming after the peace deal say
they need more land for food
not far from rudby's farm we found
people planting seeds in a recently
cleared area
the only way we have to survive is cut
tumble and plant what you see yuca corn
plantains we don't have an alternative
no support from the government they made
many promises we got rid of coca but
nothing happened in exchange
but almost say the real enemies are
powerful businesses that are clearing
much larger plots of land he cautiously
take us to another huge devastated area
until the government arrives with
technical assistance in land titling and
organization in a way that protects the
population and the environment
unfortunately deforestation will
continue
the community foresty program is small
and does not offer a long-term answer
but it shows that there are alternatives
to the devastation of the rainforest and
that those who live here can be part of
the solution for future generations
alessandra ampietti al jazeera el
capricho